welcome to opengl
part oh god what are we on
welcome to opengl part 6 here on code
tech tutorials my name is matt
and today we're going to be doing some
little black magic
trickery here on the shaders
a couple quick notes of the structural
changes
i might not get them all so i'm just
going to be quick over it
we introduced a few new shaders to mess
with
a 2d shader which we're going to put
over here
just the vertex shader and what i'm
calling a pizza frag
shader not sure if that's going to stay
but i'm just going to show you how to
work
with the basics of a shader
so what we're going to do here is we're
basically going to be going to be
drawing a
square and we're going to be using these
positions
as the xy coordinates because we're not
going to be dealing with depth
we're basically going to be rendering a
square on our screen
that matches our screen size and on
there we can apply
any algorithm we want so
first i'm just going to show you this
square because it's kind of a necessary
little uh setup thing it's pretty easy
though it's just stuff we've already
done
but for sake of clarity i will explain
it all
so if you'll recall in opengl
view space by default we have
negative 1 negative 1 down here in this
corner
and we have the positive up here in this
corner one
comma one so this point would be
top left oh i'm just gonna make a big
dot there
and this one would be bottom left
and this next one would be top right and
this next one would be
bottom right and the point of that is if
you connect them all together
you get this upside down z looking thing
which is perfect to draw as a triangle
strip
so we don't need much data we just need
these eight points
and then we can draw it as a triangle
strip
using this function here we just need to
keep track of the count
which is 8 because there's an x y and i
will show you the upload function
that we use as well for that i just
overloaded this upload mesh
to do it in this way where it returns a
draw strip
details which we've
added as a struct to the draw details
header
so that is all we need to do to have
that ready
to draw as a strip and once we do this
draw
it's basically going to fill this out so
it'll fill in this triangle and then
it'll connect it with the strip
based on this last point so if you're
using strip
well strips great for doing long arrays
of
uh i don't know if you just want a big
line or a bendy line so we might use it
more
but it's it's a pretty cool way to very
efficiently draw
so now that we have this square on the
screen we can start playing around with
it using our shaders
we have set up some different shaders
here so we're going to take a look at
that and just dive
right into it so i went ahead and
disabled the model matrix because we're
just going to fill the whole screen the
whole time
with our rectangle so we're not going to
need that right now
so the 2d vertex shader all it does is
it takes this position
as a vector and it fills in the z as
just a zero all the time
so that way we're just flat on the
screen now
in this fragment shader this is one to
just play around with
as you can see there is a circle
function that we're probably going to
use
but we're not going to mess with that
right now in fact i'm just going to
delete it
i'm also going to delete or comment out
this resolution
so what we're going to do in here is
start playing around with g frag chord
so when you're in your fragment shader
it is the space
on your screen so we can say like well
if our frag cord
is above 700 let's change the the x
color to this which would be
the red in an rgb and we can say
for the y we can do something similar if
y is over 500
so you'll see by playing around with
these numbers that this
is your view space
the opengl view space because as you can
see it is working as intended
when the x is over 700 it turns
red and when y is over 500 which is here
it turns green and then there's a mix
there so you could start playing around
with all kinds of stuff just based on
this frag chord but this frag chord is
something you natively have access to
and when you resize your screen
you do have to make sure you're resizing
your viewport
or else this won't work of course we
have that set up
in a callback already and if i comment
this out
so that it doesn't change it we will see
that the frame buffer
doesn't get changed as intended and
we're stuck with our gl clear color
which i've said is this
weird bluish color so we definitely want
that in the callback so
also in your callback in your game or
whatever you're making you can
set so that uh you know the resolution
in your shader as well
by setting the resolution to something
and playing around with that
we're not well we might mess with that
but i think what we're going to do today
is just apply a few
apps
now keep in mind here the crux of this
particular tutorial episode 6
if there's anything to get it's that you
can do whatever you want with your
shaders
at this point and by this point you
might
understand enough of what's going on to
just like
go buck wild with this because
essentially now what we can do
is pass anything we want into here like
what do we want this shader to play
around with do we want the mouse
position
because we could do that go uniform
vector because it's an x and a y
now we'll just call it u mouse pause for
now
and then here in our c plus plus code
whenever we move the mouse
we just want to update this shader based
on that we can start playing around with
that
so we do need to set a callback to set
up
glfw to keep reporting the mouse
oh and you'll also see that we made our
shader a global pointer
so we got to be sure to initialize it
but since it's global we can access it
in our other files like our callbacks
file by just using an extern and saying
it's declared already
so that way we can update our shader in
any of these callbacks and you can in
general do this
for anything you want to uh be able to
find in other
files it's not necessarily a highly
recommended
long term solution but it works well
when your program is pretty small and
you're
just making an application so now in
this
movement call back anytime there's a
mouse movement we just want to update
our shader
by going arm shader use make sure we
actually have it used otherwise we could
be writing to the wrong shader
even though we only have one right now
so
u mouse pause
and glm back to of the x
and y the scglfw takes it in as a double
work but we're gonna pass it through
as a float or pass it up to the shader
rather
okay so now here in this shader we have
our mouse pause it'll get set anytime we
need it and we can do stuff with it
do be sure to actually call this with
glfw
like we have the other ones previously
with set cursor position callback
and we're going to pass it this function
here
okay so now i went ahead and put a c out
so we should at least get our position
there oh we've got a uniform
so what you can do if this happens if
you're using the same
shader class is uh we can just go to the
stack frame if we're in debug and check
out what name it had a problem with
so we'll just keep going back we see it
got to setback 2 and that's you
mousepause so it doesn't like it for
some reason so now we know the source of
the problem we can do a little
troubleshooting
uh also i may have skipped over this but
we did add a
shader class it's just glsl shader
and really all it does is it handles
loading up
shaders with this constructor and we've
got some stuff to just call our
gl things for us that way we don't have
to have these
all over the place we just use the
shader class and call the function we
want
so the thing about these shaders and the
reason it was having an error is
when you're using these newer versions i
believe the other ones might be a little
different
uh if you try to set one of these well
the shader only actually uses the
variable if you're doing something with
it since we're not doing anything
with the mouse pause it doesn't actually
instantiate it so that's why it's
throwing an error so we do actually have
to use this
in order for this to be happy so let's
just put something in here
so we went ahead and put just a little
bit
of math in here using the mouse position
so if the frag chord is greater than the
mouse position we're going to set the
color
uh for x and y comparing to x and y so
what we'll see is a little effect
that looks a little something like this
now it seems a little reversed on the y
and i will explain why
in a second and we can fix that very
easily so to quickly visualize this in
our viewport space
our x zero is on the left side x max is
on the right side
and also in our viewport space y zero is
at the bottom
y max is at the top but if we look at
how the mouse is reporting
it is reporting y 0 at the top
and y max at the bottom so it's
essentially flipped
so all we need to do is we need to take
whatever the height of the window is
which we can get through this little
glfw
function on the fly so it's always right
take that height and minus whatever the
x is and then we'll get
results more as you're expecting so now
that we have detected the mouse position
we can render
our own cursor or draw algorithms around
the mouse
or whatever we want to do so let's go
ahead and
change our shader to render a little
something for the mouse
and we'll just use like a circle for now
to draw this little circle we're just
going to use a few
specific functions that exist within
shaders there is this distance function
where you can pass it two vectors and
it'll give you the distance between them
so if we use that pass at the mouse
position
and the frag coordinates and check how
far apart they are
if it's greater than the radius we set
which is 10 in this case we're going to
discard which means we do nothing for
this fragment
if it doesn't end up discarding it sets
the color to white
so thus anything within this radius
should be set to the color
white and congratulations you now have a
hardware rendered
so what we could do from here is we
could turn off our normal mouse
and you can do that in glfw so you just
want to write the line of code after you
set up your window glfw set input
on your window the cursor to hidden so
now when you hit play
your normal mouse is hidden and you just
have a circle
okay well there's a lot more we can get
into from here
but if you're able to understand all
this excellent if not please ask
questions down below
and we will continue with some shader
magic
henceforth thanks for watching see you
in the next one
peace out also want to say
special thanks to the patrons of this
channel
[Music]
[Music]
so
you